workers and managers at the Sun
newspaper have reacted furiously after
five senior journalists were arrested by
police investigating payments to public
officials this morning the papers
associate editor Trevor kavanah used his
column to lambast the police operation
under the headline this witch hunt has
put us behind ex-soviet states on press
freedom few minutes ago I asked him
whether he really believes that's the
case well whether that's the agenda or
not I don't know but that could easily
become the result of what I think is a
disproportionate police response to a
legitimate line of inquiry and in the
end if you are having journalists
worried about a seven o'clock knock on
the door then you ought also are going
to affect the way they think about what
stories they write and how they write
them but in a sense this is simply the
law taking its course I mean not many
journalists complained about the way
Associates of Tony Blair were treated
during the cash flow peerages inquire I
think why a lot of comments were raised
about the way Associates of Tony Blair
were questioned by police without a
simple request to come in for an
interview so no I don't agree with that
but if you read the article you will met
you'll see that I've made the point that
they are fully entitled to explore all
of the issues that they want to explore
they are entitled and to expect us to
cooperate in providing evidence when
they want it and we do what is the point
of my article is that this is utterly
disproportionate it is out of control
when you have the biggest police
operation in the country in its history
even bigger than the Lockerbie bombings
the lucky Pan Am bombing and 171 police
on this operation and expanding almost
daily including people who are on
specialized terrorist duties who will be
not looking out for people who might be
carrying or threatening to carry out
suicide bombings of the Olympics and it
has we said no one's been killed in this
case but at one also has to bear in mind
that there was a massive public outcry
summer and also that the police were
criticized for the way they went down
their inquiries after the original
investigation into phone hacking so
perhaps there's public pressure to
compensate and really clean the stables
I don't think there's much public
pressure for this frankly let me just
take those two points first of all
whatever happened last year we have paid
and 300 journalists have paid very
dearly for whatever went wrong the
newspaper has closed one of the greatest
newspapers in the history of newspapers
in Britain 300 people have lost their
jobs and is it right that the police who
perhaps didn't do their job properly at
that time should go to the other end of
the extreme of the spectrum and be
hauling 30 journalists out of their beds
at seven o'clock in the morning when a
polite request and perhaps a knock on
the door to some other time certainly by
at less than 20 specialized police would
deliver the same result I mean what
could be done though now that we do have
as you say these three police inquiries
under way is the leveson inquiry how how
could a sense of proportion be restored
well I mean if we accept that this is
disproportionate and that a sense of
proportion doesn't need to be restored
then you wind down some of the
activities why do you need 20 police
officers to raid the home of a single
journalist who would be happy to
cooperate without that pressure why do
you need 171 people to be operating on
three different inquiries which is far
greater than the number that were
involved in as I say any other major
police investigation no murder inquiry
no terrorist inquiry would involve that
many people yet but the difficulty is
now that the documentation is out there
more than 3 million documents in some
cases allegations are there was an
attempt to dispose of documents that
have been subsequently recovered and you
know that is the the agony if you like
of news international that all this
material now is in the police's domain
if it's there please don't really have
much alternative but to investigate it
they don't have much of alternative but
to investigate it but they don't need
either since they have these millions of
documents and emails and other receipts
to go raiding people at seven o'clock in
the morning before their
about and in such heavy-handed
proportions I mean look we've got 30
arrests so far not a single charge has
been made no one's appeared in court no
one's been convicted they're all
innocent until proved guilty and yet
they are their lives are on hold their
careers are potentially being ruined
okay people will say we deserve it maybe
that might be an argument but I don't
believe it's true I believe they deserve
it I mean there are those saying that
the best course for news corporation
would be to simply get rid of the papers
in Britain because they're just a sort
of trouble it was that business move why
would they do that well then what do you
believe Adam that whatever has happened
justify such action do you believe that
anyone do you think our readers would
like to see the back of their favorite
newspapers it's a monstrous and frankly
it is exactly the ambition of our
critics and our enemies on other
newspapers and in political parties and
the particular parts of other political
parties who would love to see that
that's their objective that's their
driving goal to see News International
destroyed and it is to say the least as
I say this morning utterly out of
proportion